also das lka hat den status der
genesenen der fast über nacht muss man
sagen von sechs auf drei monate halbiert
wie ist das ganze wirklich passiert da
gibt es ja große diskussionen ab wann
waren sie informiert wann hat wer mit
wem gesprochen aber das habe ich doch
schon auf gesagt also die auf fachebene
fand die debatte schon eine ganze zeit
lang statt so ähnlich wie sehr gerade
geführt haben und also als ich dann also
im freitags also im bundesrat und so
gesetz verabschiedet hatte zur krone
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung
bz bis zu dem zeitpunkt hatte ich selbst
also an dieser debatte um die dauer des
genesenen status nicht teilgenommen also
wieder da wussten sie davon dass die
geführt wird und war ihre fachebene
informieren ebene war informiert dass
die fachebene sei informiert aber ich
hatte ich persönlich hatte nicht haben
sie im ministerium nicht im griff die
sich nicht informieren und da ich habe
ehrlich gesagt ich also da ich auch
wissenschaftler bin gehe ich ihnen sehr
viele sach diskussionen reihen also was
wo ich mir habe sagen lassen dass man
vorhabe vorgängers nicht gemacht hat
weil mich einfach interessiert in dem
sind also diese debatten interessieren
mich halt aber ich arbeite halt immer
ein stück nach dem anderen ab und womit
wir uns an dem freitag beschäftigen das
war ja auch die beschlusslage ist wie
wir die isolation und die quarantäne
damit hatte ich mich sehr intensiv
beschäftigt aber das ist jetzt bei
demnach aber nicht gewusst immer wieder
musste er wieder davon ausgehen dass er
sie auf ihrer seite hat also haben sie
das so kommuniziert vorher nein also ich
war ja also ich wie gesagt ich hatte ja
gar nicht damit gerechnet wie ich gerade
aus führe dass das an dem tag also mit
auf die
seiten des robert koch instituts kommt
also sie bleiben dabei er will hat sie
in keiner form informiert ich bin nicht
informiert aber das ist das habe ich
doch schon eben beinahe ich muss auch
mal klar sagen das habe ich doch schon
im beisein von herrn wähler in der
pressekonferenz in genau gab er weitere
diskussionen darum heraus will es gibt
das mal so richtig vorstellen ja genau
es gibt immer diskussionen also ich lese
da alle möglichen räuberpistolen also
ich hätte das also angewiesen oder was
auch immer so lasst uns einfach ist der
fdp-general ist eine räuberpistole
naja das nämlich angedeutet das was ich
habe nicht gehört also die schätze den
fdp-general und habe das von ihm nicht
gehört aber aber die menschen fragen sie
herr lauterbach und das gehört ja zur
debatte dazu herr wieder und sie da
denkt man ja eigentlich sie telefonieren
relativ viel sie haben wir auch unser
tag schreiben sms e-mails was auch immer
und bei so einer entscheidenden frage
können sich viele eben nicht vorstellen
dass er wieder da wirklich in
irgendeiner form einfach allein
gehandelt haben soll ja dass das oft
dass er diesen beschluss also
auf die homepage gestellt hat und somit
wurde daher quasi
automatisch über die verweisung zurecht
das wusste ich nicht dass wir doch nicht
mehr vorkommen ist dass ich damit nicht
zufrieden gewesen bin was haben sie dann
wieder gesagt dass wir haben uns auf
jeden fall ausgesprochen aber die was
klar ist was was viel wichtiger ist ich
habe das fahren geändert und das habe
ich aber auch schon dabei ich muss immer
nach aber lassen ich glaube man hat
haben bisher will er dann noch im amt
naja dann mehrere somit alle vorher also
vor bevor wir also zum abend jagen und
zu wort ich arbeite tatsächlich also eng
mit energie auf verschiedensten ebenen
zusammen auch mit herrn wähler aber
nicht nur wir haben sehr regelmäßige
treffen an schade und so weiter und ich
habe mich auch inhaltlich vor die der
diskussion gestellt bevor die richter in
der vor dem beschluss gestellt aber dass
das nicht geht dass ich quasi also
selbst also wie ein bürger erfahren dass
wird dass das jetzt schon der neue
status ist und so das ist ja klar und
darüber ist offen gesprochen worden und
ich habe das verfahren hat verändert das
jetzt änderungen die also politisch
relevant sind selbst dann wenn die
sachdiskussion also geführt worden ist
dass das mit mir vorher abgestimmt sein
muss und erst dann kommt der vorzug das
haben wir sofort eingeführt man muss
allerdings der ehrenrettung gegen sagen
das war auch das erste mal dass das
gesetz in dieser form angewendet sie
stehen so hinwiler viele würden sich ja
fragen wenn man so informiert und wenn
das so stimmt was sie sagen warum ist er
doch noch im amt er hat also zwei jahre
lang eine sehr wichtige gute arbeit
gemacht und genießt weiter man vertrauen
so einfach ist das aber ich trotzdem
trotzdem also sage ich also das hier war
nicht in ordnung das wird sich auch
nicht wiederholen will ihn einmal
dennoch noch mal zeigen was der
fdp-generalsekretär erzählen will gesagt
hat was er gesagt haben sie haben das
nicht mitbekommen und er hat sich sehr
klar dazu geäußert und zwar das
vertrauen der fdp kann sich ja wieder
aber aufgrund dieser neuerlichen
verfehlungen die ja leider kein
einzelfall darstellt nicht mehr sicher
sein also die fdp zweifelt an händler
dann ist das eben so also ich kann nur
davor warnen
man muss auch ein bisschen dankbarkeit
geben das robert-koch-institut hat zwei
jahre lang genau wie das
gesundheitsministerium eine
fantastische arbeit gemacht und also die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
arbeiten dort an der grenze der
belastbarkeit
das gilt auch für mein haus für das bmw
für das besinnt gesundes
gesundheitsregion und da muss sich der
chef wenn es also eine wenn es ein
problem gibt also wie es hier mit wie
leute mit herrn wähler offenbar gab muss
sich der chef auch vor die behörde vor
die einrichtung stellen um die um den
wert der einrichtung zu schützen da darf
man nicht leichtfertig sicher ist aber
auch dass sich das nicht wiederholen
darf jetzt hat in osnabrück bereits in
einem konkreten fall die
verfassungswidrigkeit der kürzung des
genießen des status festgestellt wie
viele urteile dieser art wollen sie da
kassieren bis sie die entscheidung des
rk ii rückgängig macht ja das ist ja was
anderes also das urteil in osnabrück
betrifft nur die frage ob dieses
verwaltungsrecht also richtig ist also
dass das lka selbst quasi entscheiden
kann wie lange ist der genießen den
status denn das ist de facto jetzt so
dass also diese aufgabe klar gesetzt an
das robert koch institut übertragen
worden ist und das ist die rechts
mechanik deren verfassungsrechtlich kite
hier geprüft wird und also kann man
unterschiedlicher meinung zu sagen aber
so wir haben es ist wir haben es mit der
somit den ländern auch mit der fdp und
so weiter haben wir es also wir haben es
ohne wir haben einen wir haben
beschlossen
und die länder waren dafür die
fraktionen waren dafür wäre es
beschlossen davon unabhängig ist die
frage also wie ist das mit den drei
monaten das heißt selbst wenn jetzt
diese klage durchgänge das ja nur ein
einziger fahrer ein einzelfall
entschieden worden in einem also da muss
man mal schauen wird aber selbst über
die klage durch
und der mechanismus wäre dann weg der
automatismus wäre weg dann müsste ich
das ja wieder entscheiden denn dann
müsste ich ja nur einmal sekunden dass
der bürger spricht dann müsste ich per
rechtsverordnung die arbeit auf mich
nehmen die quasi ich bestimme das dann
und so weiter das würde ja nicht
automatisch bedeuten dass die drei
monate wechselt hat das lka zu viel
macht finde ich nicht also ich glaube
dass das rk ii in einiger hinsicht also
auch international
als vorbildlich betrachtet wird beachtet
wird und ich habe eben schon gesagt also
mit mir grad durch die mikrowelle fahren
also mit dem modell des rk ist das ist
so dass das sucht seinesgleichen von
daher man darf jetzt also mach ich
hielte es für falsch das rkw klein oder
schlecht zu reden das ist eine
einrichtung um die wir international
beneidet werden herr lauterbach zum
abschluss unseres gesprächs will ich
noch mal darauf eingehen was wir morgen
fordert sehen wir bereits gesagt sie
wollen das nicht sie sind dagegen anders
als bild ab wann
sagen sie ist reicht
wie lange muss das dauern ein jahr zwei
jahre drei jahre wann es genug ich
glaube
wenn es wirklich gut läuft dann wird es
wie vor kaufen wir kriegen die omikron
welle in den griff die zahlen sinken wir
lockern wir haben das aber dann so
gemacht dass wir eine deutlich geringere
zahl von sterbefällen und
schwerstkranken gab dann alles wie sonst
gehabt hätten das muss ja auch erklärt
werden war der bürger denkt was soll das
alles wofür machen wir das wir haben ja
auch erfolge im ausland sieht man die
erfolge die wir haben zum teil sehr viel
klarer weil in vielen anderen ländern
hat man diese sterbeziffern nicht und
wenn wir im herbst dann tatsächlich eine
impfpflicht bekämen dann glaube ich ist
der spuk vorbei war das gehend weil wir
damit also die impflücken geschlossen
wenn sie sagen im herbst ist der spuk
vorbei bedeutet das dann auch am ende
der masten pflicht das also steht dahin
aber es wird wirklich davon abhängen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt ob er die
eben schlicht schaffen oder nicht also
aus ihrer sicht hängt die masken pflicht
an der impfen einig würde die maske will
ich jetzt nicht da alleine also ob wir
wirklich im herbst wieder in eine
problematische situation kommen wo dann
vieles diskutiert wird welche maske wo
wir zu machen was machen wir in den
restaurants und so werden wir uns dies
diskussion für den herbst ersparen
wollen und auch unseren kindern übrigens
sind die schulen laufen so brauchen wir
die impfpflicht wie oft herr lauterbach
träumen sie positiv wie oft machen sie
morgens positiv auf man hat manchmal das
gefühl sie sehen eben viele gefahren
aber nicht so ganz das licht ich sehe
ich gesagt das licht ganz klar ich habe
sogar noch gesagt wir kommen gut durch
diese mikrowelle besser als andere
länder und wir werden im herbst also
wenn wir den pflicht durch bekommen
haben werden wir das gröbste hinter uns
haben im herbst ist der spuk vorbei
haben sie gesagt herzlichen dank karl
lauterbach herzlichen dank dass sie sich
immer wieder stellen und das war's mit
den richtigen fragen mit
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach
[Musik]